[Music]
the teacher explained to me that she did
in fact kick
my child but that it was part of a game
they're disturbing allegations made in a
lawsuit against ccsd a mother claims her
child who was on the autism spectrum was
kicked as part of a game
the school and the district deny those
claims the i-team's david charns with
what the family says and the internal
emails he's uncovered
i knew something was wrong because she
was
acting different from her norm jessica
hernandez is talking about her
seven-year-old daughter up until october
of last year she was a student here at
joseph neal steam academy but something
happened that led mom to pull her from
class she was uncomfortable with her own
person in a lawsuit filed against ccsd
hernandez alleges her daughter who was
on the spectrum was on the receiving end
of physical force verbal abuse and
humiliation it hurt it hurt her feelings
and it hurt her body the lawsuit
referring to one reported incident
involving a quote game where the teacher
kicks the student on their rear end or
legs hernandez alleges one teacher
played the so-called game with another
student in class then played it with her
daughter the aid is now i-team filed a
public records request with ccsd for any
document regarding the alleged kicking
game in this email a teacher wrote quote
there was no kicking involved in that
the game involved the teacher lightly
bumping or tapping the toe of her shoe
against a student's heel or ankle the
teacher picked her foot up and
nudged the boy in a kicking manner my
daughter took it to be kicking she
stated it was kicking the lawsuit claims
the alleged kicking constituted a
battery because of that hernandez says
ccsd should have not only informed her
but should have also filed the
appropriate paperwork court documents
revealing ccsd police did not open any
kind of investigation and there were no
cameras recording in the classroom they
also didn't fill out the 624 form
required for aversive intervention if
they won't report it down and they won't
record it down and they won't make sure
that someone is aware then i need to
according to the documents the i-team
obtained school leaders and teachers
involved met with hernandez those
documents saying with regards to the
kicking game it was decided that this
would not be played anymore in class and
it hasn't been the teacher explained to
me that she did in fact kick
my child but that it was part of the
game internal documents indicating the
teachers vehemently denied the claims
saying the accusations are completely
false this is really just about
a large uncontrollable school district
neil hyman is hernandez's attorney the
mother needs to be notified it needs to
go up the chain of command could this
just be a case of a misunderstanding of
we were playing a game no
hernandez now homeschooling her daughter
i
struggle to
let her out of my sight now
she says her daughter made a lot of
progress at the school but regressed in
the months before she pulled her out i
feel like we've been further cut off
from the outside world a recent filing
in the case says the district and
hernandez are settling out of court
though the terms haven't been released
we reached out to the district and a
spokesperson said they do not comment on
pending litigation but lawyers for the
district deny the allegation in court
documents with one teacher writing in
the documents we received that the
allegations were quote offensive i'm
david charns live local now